-Guys, I have some exciting
news.
This is very --
a couple years ago,
I partnered with
Warby Parker, okay?
And I created Spinnies, okay?
Now, this is -- I was waiting --
So, like, when I wait online,
I always spin
my sunglasses around.
So I go, "Why don't we put,
like, glasses
on, like, a ball
bearing or something on the end
to make them, like, really spin
so you can get, like, a good
kind of whip to them, you know?
So, we created Spinnies,
alright?
We sold out in four days.
100% --
[ Cheers and applause ]
100% of the proceeds
went to the Pupils Project,
which provides free eye exams
and eyeglasses
to kids in school.
And it's amazing.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's the best.
You're a kid.
You're at school.
You don't know why
they're not doing well.
They come right to your school,
check all the kids,
and then they get to choose
from their frames, you know,
and makes it them feel good.
It's awesome.
Today, I'm announcing a new
partnership with Warby Parker.
-What?
-I have a new invention.
[ Drumroll ]
Well, hold on a second.
-Oh.
-I was in my dressing room
one night after this thing,
'cause it was a hit,
and I love working with Warby.
They're great.
I go, "I have a new idea."
Look at these.
They're called -- Can we --
They're called Flip --
There's, like,
a 180-degree hinge.
-Right.
-And, so, it's a black sunglass,
but they have
a fun color inside.
And then you flip
the arms backwards.
-Backwards.
-And then -- Yeah.
And then it turns back
into the other side,
which is a fun color.
-So you can be, like,
regular and a little extra.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah. Exactly.
They're called Flippies.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow. Let me see.
-They're real.
Okay? This is real.
I'm unboxing.
This is an unboxing right now.
I'm opening up. Look at this.
♪♪
Yeah.
-Ooh.
Snappy. Nice case.
-Flippies.
Now look at this.
Check this out, right?
They made these.
So, you wear your sunglasses.
You're like, "Oh, that's cool."
-What?
-What's up?
You guys good? You cool?
[ Cheers and applause ]
You take them off.
♪♪
[ Air horn blows ]
Wow!
Again -- Right?
You want to feel fun.
So 100% goes to
the Pupils Project, alright?
So not only are you
getting two pairs of sunglasses,
you're also helping a child
who needs glasses.
[ Cheers and applause ]
They're out officially
right now.
Everyone in our audience
has a pair under their seat.
-Whoa!
-Go ahead and check them out.
Open them up.
Yeah, check them out.
Open them up. Put them on.
Do you have them?
Do you got them?
This looks like chaos.
Yeah. Look at this.
-There we go!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Everyone got them?
Alright, everyone turn --
everyone turn
your Flippies to the black side.
-Black side.
-Yeah.
And let's try these.
Put them to the black side.
Yeah, flip them around.
It's going to take a little bit.
Wait.
Look at how cool everyone looks.
Can we get a shot
of the audience?
-Whoa. Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-This is good.
Yeah. That's right.
Now -- Looking good.
Now, everyone, why don't you
flip to the blue side.
-Ooh!
♪♪
Hold on.
Look at you right there.
Look at you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Get up! Come on!
[ Air horn blows ]
Yeah! That's what I'm talking
about right there.
Guys, Flippies
are available now at
every Warby Parker store
and online at warbyparker.com.
Check them out.
Get yours today.
There's a very limited quantity.
Thank you to everybody
at Warby Parker for being
a great partner.
And enjoy your Flippies.
We'll be right back
with more "Tonight Show"!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
[ Air horn blows ]